[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez pour ce
nouveau numéro de la grande interview
alors vous le savez la crise sanitaire
que le monde d'hier de traverser laisse
déjà derrière lui elle les stigmates
d'une crise économique de nombreux
secteurs sont déjà touchés notamment
celui du spectacle et c'est de ce
secteur dont on va parler aujourd'hui
avec notre invité olivier d'arbois
président du syndicat prodiss le
syndicat national à du spectacle musical
et de variétés olivier d'arbois bonjour
et merci d'être avec nous aujourd'hui
sur rt france bonjour après plus de deux
mois et demi sans spectacle et ça leur
ouvre enfin j'imagine que c'est déjà un
soulagement pour vous disons que les
annonces du premier ministre hier nous
ont donné l'espoir qui effectivement
déjà cette crise sanitaire est en train
de se dissiper
donc ça c'est effectivement un très bon
signe est-ce que nous allons redémarrer
les spectacles bien sûr on a envie de
redémarrer après trois mois de d'arrêt
après il va falloir redémarrer avec tout
un protocole et de ne pas non plus aller
trop vite dans ce redémarrage alors ce
sera des marches sous conditions avec
port du masque obligatoire distanciation
physique gestion des flux vous disiez ne
pas vouloir redémarrer trop vite il va
falloir aussi d'adapter ce démarrage son
redémarrage
oui tout à fait mais il faut bien avoir
la connaissance de comment fonctionne le
spectacle donc dans un premier temps on
a un certain nombre de deux jours de
semaine incompressibles une période
incompressible pour redémarrer pour
redémarrer nos productions c'est à dire
qu'il faut non seulement concevoir le
spectacle le répéter et puis le
commercialiser simultanément donc si
vous voulez vous avez quelques semaines
voire quelques mois incompressibles
on ne redémarre pas comme ça on et off
ça ne ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça on
doit avoir un certain un certain laps de
temps avant de bien entendu pouvoir
présenter les spectacles et les tournées
qu'avant que les tournées reprennent
si d'ici aux 6-10 tensions physiques il
y a justement vous parlez d'une jauge
qui ne va pas rentrer forcément dans
dans les budgets est ce que sur cette
jauge vous attendez une aide de la part
de l'état alors on attend une aide
ailleurs s'est passé et éventuellement
sur la compensation de cette jauge
dégradé que nous attendons une haine où
on attend une aide si vous voulez un
plan de sauvegarde de nos entreprises
mais c'est bien au delà du redémarrage
c'est à dire que avec trois mois de non
activité où les billetteries sont à
l'arrêt l'impact financier est énorme
nous avons d'ailleurs à ce sujet la
commandite et une audit nous parlons de
1 milliard 800 millions de chiffre
d'affaires affalé ce qui est énorme avec
une une casse des entreprises qui est
également très conséquente
donc il est clair que pour redémarrer il
va falloir un plan de sauvegarde
on y travaille depuis un certain temps
mais sans des moyens massifs par les
pouvoirs publics il sera difficile de
sauver les entreprises
nous parlons d'une entreprise sur deux
qui a un risque sévère de déposer de
faire faillite dans les antres les six
prochains mois et jusqu'à enfin toute
l'année 2021 c'est à dire un certain
nombre d'entreprises quelle qu'elle soit
leur taille qui risquent de dévisser en
termes de pertes sur cette grande
période on parle de plus de 2 milliards
d'euros est ce que déjà c'est un chiffre
que vous confirmez ainsi
la situation reste la même jusqu'à fin
août et c'est justement ce chiffre qu'on
pourrait éventuellement combler en
aidant les entreprises de la culture
nous notre étude est la part de civils
et du début de l'année en fin de 2 mars
à partir du moment où les activités ont
été interdites jusqu'au 31 décembre nous
avons préféré aller jusqu'au 31 décembre
pour une raison très simple pour
calculer les pertes exacte des sociétés
des entreprises donc le milliard nous on
est sur un entrain milliards 8 et 2
milliards
l'ensemble de nos entreprises vont
accuser une casse réels c'est-à-dire
comptable de plus deux autour de 200
millions d'euros alors ça ne paraît ça
ne paraît pas énorme comme ça mais quand
vous savez les modèles économiques dans
nos métiers c'est 600 ou 700 de plein
régime pour arriver à 7
cet équilibre ça va induire énormément
de casse sociale du chômage et cette
fois pas du chômage partiel mais du
chômage
durel du chômage réel et puis et puis
effectivement au niveau culture ça va si
vous voulez privé la diffusion la
diversité l'émergence de nouveaux
artistes c'est considérable et les
effets les effets sont considérables et
également les retombées économiques
parce qu'il faut savoir que lorsque nous
produisons un euro de billetterie de
chiffre d'affaires c'est une
répercussion sur qu'on jauge entre 2 et
2 et demi et 4 euros de retombées
économiques
si vous regardez les festivals festival
ou
le chiffre d'affaires du festival est de
10 ou 15 millions d'euros ça produit
deux fois voire trois fois plus en
retombées économiques locales régionales
des retombées directes par les
transports de tourisme hôtellerie mais
aussi des retombées sur le tissu local
des des petits commerçants des
entreprises donc c'est énorme
le marasme que la culture que le
spectacle vivant privé est en train de
subir il y aura des conséquences au delà
de notre filière forcément vous le dites
les conséquences sont forcément énorme
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées est-ce que vous
parlez aussi avec vos collègues des
autres disciplines et est ce que tous
font vraiment le même constat que vous
aujourd'hui ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il ya certainement eu des séquences
plus prioritaires avec d'autres dans
d'autres secteurs
mais aujourd'hui il est temps de sauver
ce pan de la culture qui représentait
par le spectacle vivant et donc il
devient urgent puisque le doubs seront
comme je le disait l'un des derniers
secteurs à redémarrer les tur gens de
mettre sur pied un plan de sauvegarde et
un plan de relance donc as à cet effet
nous parlons avec le ministère et nous
parlons également avec le ministère de
l'économie de façon à ce que nos
entreprises soient sauvés sur tout le
maillage culturel soit sauvé il ya les
entreprises mais il ya aussi tout
l'écosystème bien sûr il ya énormément
d'entreprises qui seront en difficulté
à cause de cette crise des hommes et des
femmes aussi
forcément on parlait tout à l'heure un
petit peu des intermittents j'aimerais
qu'on en parle un peu plus maintenant
ils vont être nombreux forcément à
vouloir tout ce travail et dès que ce
sera possible il y aura beaucoup de
demandes pour peut-être un petit peu
moins de places comment on imagine cette
reprise du travail pour les
intermittents
ça va être graduelle si vous voulez on
retrouvera pas le marché que nous avons
quitté en 2021 sas et il faudra
reconstruire le marché ça prendra
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
avant d'être à plein régime
telle qu'on connaissait j'exerce ce
métier avant avant la crise ça va
prendre quand même quelques temps mais
je suis assez confiant le jeu est
confiant dans le sens où la nature
reprend ses droits
vous l'avez constaté et je pense que le
marché reprendra ses droits
donc faut-il améliorer dans le futur
certaine je peux vous dire nous avons
été absolument délaissé par les
assureurs par exemple certains en ont
parlé
est-ce qu'il va falloir
recréer justement avec les assureurs de
nouvelles de nouvelles façons d'assurer
nos spectacles et notre filière bien
entendu il y aura des discussions il y
aura l'après crise pour l'instant on se
focalise sur sauver les entreprises de
façon à ce que ça redémarre
est ce que ce sera aussi à vous
professionnels du spectacle d'aider
cette transition est peut-être parfois
de de rassurer les spectateurs pour les
ramener une nouvelle fois vers l'est
vers les salles oui bras bien entendu
c'est notre métier aussi d'accueillir un
d'accueillir les spectateurs c'est notre
métier de toute l'année donc on saura
être au rendez vous à ce niveau là moi
ce que je voudrais dire c'est tout de
même les mesures de distanciation les
masques et toutes les mesures barrières
font que nous ne sommes pas non plus au
fait c'est pas le meilleur c'est la
meilleure situation pour parler à nos
publics et leur dire venez bien entendu
est-ce que vous avez le premier réflexe
comme vous voyez on ouvre une salle de
spectacle confiné où tout le monde doit
être doit d'observer des mesures
barrières avec les masques avec un
maître de distanciation est ce que ça
vous incite à rentrer dans les salles je
n'en sais rien j'espère que ça ne sera
pas une
voilà ça ne sera pas une
barrière mais je pense que ce que nous
attendons c'est effectivement la
possibilité de rouvrir sans ces mesures
barrières le plus vite possible sans
cette distanciation pour nous la
distanciation de toute manière on n'en
parle même pas ça ne fonctionne pas
comme pour des raisons économiques et en
même temps des tic
si vous voulez le spectacle vivant si ça
se passe dans un contexte très clinique
où l'émotion ne circule pas puisque
l'émotion il ya une distance entre le
public entre chaque membre du public ça
ne fonctionne pas mais si vous voulez
tous ces mesures barrières en plus
n'incite pas forcément le public à se
précipiter dans l'est dans les salles
dont il va falloir un certain temps pour
que pour je dirais oui donner de la
confiance à nos publics
et bien voila merci beaucoup c'est la
fin de cette grande interview merci à
vous reliez d'arbois d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui merci également à vous
de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez déjà
retrouver cette émission en replay et en
podcast sur rt france point tva très
bientôt pour un nouveau numéro de la
grande interview sur arte france
[Musique]